Beth Chapman talks about deaths in the
first teaser for the new season of dogs
most wanted and it's absolutely
heartbreaking I haven't gotten past the
place where I'm still putting a pillow
where she was and covering it up like
the jailhouse escape right I mean it and
then I wake up bill likes ear and it
doesn't register Betty Turner I'm still
there so it's really a morbid thing
WGN series paid tribute to the late beth
chapman following her last days on the
job I think that everything is a
milestone you know every every milestone
that you meet you're like yes I made it
to Mother's Day I made it to Easter and
we're just living every day as much as
we can to the fullest that we can and
trying to hit every milestone that we
can you know and we're just gonna have
fun and love each other and laugh all
the way and when it ends it ends her
therapy you know was hunting bounty
hunting catching a bad guy fixing him
the new season will take fans behind the
scenes of bests final days as she
battled throat cancer once you find out
that it's an incurable lung cancer
there's no Stage five in the trailer
Duane dog Chapman gets choked up as he
talks about his beloved wife I'd love
her that I'll do anything
Eadie spoke to the reality star just
days after his partner lost her battle
with cancer you guys build something
that is an American original thank you
but you build it together yes how where
are you now when you you know when they
say let's go shoot and you're looking
for that partner
well you know four to three years she
knew this might happen so she would say
yeah who's going to sit next to you
and I said no one
together you better not let another girl
take my place I said I'm all stew wGNS
dogs Most Wanted will premiere its new
season on September 4th
[Music]
you